hi Jo Tom I am so excited to be here I
gave a talk here last year in the B
track on accessibility of web components
if you cut that talk you may remember a
secret thing that happened at the end
which resulted in real-life tacos
Ted Mikko I actually I gotta say I like
pizza more than tacos if I could choose
I would always choose pizza every time I
really wanted to work pizza into this
talk somehow and at the risk of sounding
cheesy we are going to make this happen
so hold on a second hi I'd like to order
pizza yeah let's do one cheese and one
pepperoni yeah you're gonna bring it to
Marcy Sutton Jay s comp and track a yeah
you have 30 minutes thanks bite
okay so now we can get started
that's that thing in the time it takes
for this pizza to get here I'm gonna
tell you about something I'm really
passionate about which is accessibility
we're going to talk about automated
accessibility testing which is a way
that you can actually work accessibility
into your workflow I'm Marcy Sutton I'm
a developer in Seattle I currently work
at a company called substantial and I
want to give them a shout out because I
went to substantial to learn about
software testing and get and pragmatic
software practices and now I'm up here
giving a talk at Jas cough so I'm pretty
stoked that I got to go work there and
learn this stuff in July I'm actually
moving over to Adobe where I'll be an
accessibility engineer on anything
web-based across the company so I'm
pretty stoked about that
I'm also an angular core team member I'm
the primary contributor to ng Aria which
is the accessibility module and since
August I've been working on material
design for angular which is a component
library we'll talk about it a little bit
but the focus today is obviously
automated accessibility testing my
slides are on github they're all
there's a shortcut from my website Marcy
Sutton comm /j s conf 2015 so
accessibility the answer no more
inclusive web it's the way that we can
build websites and mobile apps and
experiences that work for more people
because 1/5 of the population on the
planet has some kind of disability so if
we don't if we keep not addressing
accessibility we're leaving out a ton of
people PETA has also always answer just
saying I'm gonna gloss over some
accessibility basics because we're
focusing on something really technical
automated testing but you should become
familiar with accessibility basics I
have them listed in my slides and
there's a link to more principles if you
want to read more but some things you
should be considering if you're web
developer are text alternatives
including alt text for images form
labels off screen text if you have
graphical like infographics and things
like that document structure and
hierarchy which will touch a little bit
today and talking about headings HTML
semantics which you should definitely be
using use real buttons and so on
keyboard interactivity making sure that
if you're creating custom controls that
they are reachable and operable from the
keyboard and they have adequate focus
Styles color contrast that's a huge
population of people as well as keyboard
interactivity not just blind people or
you know people with deafness they're
hard-of-hearing these visual
disabilities are a little more subtle
and they affect huge populations of
people so color contrast is in that
category and visual contrast in general
which even my slides this projector
looks a little different than my
computer screen so my slides need
adequate contrast and then lastly if
you're building single page apps or
client rendered applications you should
be familiar with focus management it
means that you are guiding the users
keyboard focus around your app so that
if you're opening dialogues
or bottom sheets or other components
that they their focus isn't being
dropped that you're actually curating
their focus experience so that you can
notify them when things are opening and
are happening and I have some resources
at the end if you want to learn more
about that but there was a time when I
didn't know accessibility like you have
to start somewhere and so it's important
to recognize that you're not going to be
perfect at this right away Jake the dog
from adventure time says dude sucking at
something is the first step towards
becoming sort of good at something and
that's okay you know it's it's not a
something that's gonna be perfect all
the time but every little bit of
accessibility that you contribute is so
appreciated and so needed that you can
just learn more as you go and it's a
huge win anytime there's something for
accessibility that we're including but
we're developers this is a JavaScript
conference so we are going to let the
tooling that we are already familiar
with using javascript tasks runners and
tools that we love to work with because
they're technical and geeky we can use
this tooling to do some heavy lifting
for us help us identify accessibility
issues in our apps the low-hanging fruit
stuff that you don't need to pay someone
to find if you can automate that you can
free up people's time to test things
that are a little bit more nuanced and
more subjective so we're going to talk
about manual testing you know where do I
start when I out at a website for
accessibility then we'll move into what
I'm calling sorta automated testing not
rent not looking at the rendered source
code but using some tools to help you
identify issues and then lastly we'll
talk about what you really came to hear
about which is definitely automated
testing and how you can incorporate
accessibility testing so for example if
you could prevent a broken build from
going out into the wild automating that
so it can withhold a deployment or of
some kind but the elephant in the room
that I have to mention to you because
we're talking about automated
accessibility testing is that it is no
substitute for real user feedback
including people with disabilities you
want to have people testing your apps so
that they can tell you when something
really sucks like Peter Griffin saying
what really grinds his gears because
that feedback is so valuable so that
should be part of your strategy as well
and even you know getting to
accessibility earlier in the design
process - those are all very important
things but we are here to talk about
automated testing which is an important
thing to know how to do so the first
thing that I do when I look at a website
to figure out what's the accessibility
situation is I just tab through the page
with the keyboard so we're gonna do that
real quick I'm going to show you gov dot
uk' which has pretty good focus styles
it has some solid blocks of color the
text links are either bolded with blue
text or bold with white text and if we
start tabbing through the page the focus
indicator is really obvious it's orange
color on whatever the other background
color is and it actually really shows
you effectively where you are on a web
page it has been pointed out to me that
this is technically not mechag double-a
compliant and that's because there isn't
quite enough visual contrast to meet
that standard but what they could do to
fix it is either white in the visual
contrast between the foreground and
background colors or you could make the
text bigger so you have some things that
you could do to to fix this but compared
to most websites gov dot uk' is awesome
and it's winning the focus style like
they do it the best I have any type of
scene so they deserves a pat on the back
okay so that's the first thing I do the
next thing I do which I'm not gonna
spend a whole lot of time on but you
should be demoing in screen readers I'm
gonna show you SoundCloud in Safari with
voiceover which is the screen reader on
the Mac but it's not the most used
screen reader ie and jaws on Windows is
the most used and VBA which is an open
source screen reader and Firefox are
well used
there's also mobile screen readers iOS
Safari with voiceover is great talkback
with Firefox and Android is great but
you should be checking your stuff in a
screen reader so that you kind of know
what's going on in your app so we're
going to demo okay so I'm gonna hit
command f5 and fire up voiceover
voiceover on Safari you're three months
on cloud
window you're three months out cloud
eight visited link SoundCloud see how
the SoundCloud link muting it is just a
graphic there's no text saying
SoundCloud but when I use the screen
reader SoundCloud has done a great job
and adding text alternatives to their
images so when I tab through it with a
screen reader even though it's a graphic
button I get some text because it says
SoundCloud on it
visited link link link upload banner
seven items Marcy underlined SSS is
avatar Marcy underlined sss poppet
button so this is a pop-up little toggle
thing if i hit enter tracks link it
opens the popup and it sends my focus
into it now i'm in this this list of
currently on the list inside of a muting
mute it um so we're in this little
pop-up list and to get out it's really
easy i just hit escape
Marcy underlined SSS is Avatar Marcy
underlying SSS pop-up button banner
seven items
voiceover off so that's just a really
quick demo with voiceover to show you
what it's like to use it and again you
just turn it on with command f5 on the
Mac and then you can go check it out and
I will say Safari works a little better
than Chrome but it's a good thing to do
every now and then so that's one of the
first things I do now I want to get into
sort of automated testing using a few
tools that I think are useful something
that you should be checking for our
headings and semantic structure so the
web was created for documents we're
creating applications it doesn't mean
that because you're creating an
application you get to throw out the
semantic structure and not care about it
because a user with a screen reader can
use the your heading structure to get an
overall picture of what is on your site
they can also navigate by headings and
other landmarks
so this Firefox web developer toolbar I
love because it can show you the heading
structure so if you install the toolbar
go to information and then view document
outline you can see the heading
structure on your page and I still use
this it's just it's probably the only
feature in this toolbar I still use
but for my tumblr accessibility wins
when I was hacking at a tumblr theme I
could go and see what the heading
structure was make adjustments and then
it will show you when everything is all
aligned so next I want to tell you about
the chrome accessibility developer tools
which you it's a must-have for any web
developer these days it's great for
checking the overall page accessibility
for any website and especially in active
development it caches kind of the
low-hanging fruit of things that you
like missing labels and things so let's
go check out and awed it okay so I'm
gonna pick on CNN today let's go see
what crusty accessibility things they
have going on so I'm going to open up
the dev tools and I have the extension
installed so under audits I get an
accessibility audit which I can go and
run and it will go and it will look at
their site analyze it run tests against
it and it will report back to you what's
wrong with it so they are missing a
bunch of form labels if I drill down
into it I can look at the specific node
that is a problem I can reveal it in the
elements panel and go over here in the
element inspector you get a couple
little add-ons actually with the
extension you get this accessibility
properties panel and it will show you
some of the accessibility information
I'm using Chrome Canary which actually
has a dev tools experiment if you're
curious I can send you the information
later because it's sort of hard to
enable but the deal is that this
extension will be moved into the dev
tools at some point and their Google is
working on that right now
but if you haven't enabled in Chrome
Canary you get this secret panel of
extra information of the accessibility
node and this will tell you what role it
has if it has any Aria attributes and so
on that highlights an important concept
that I want you to know which is about
the accessibility tree the accessibility
tree is something created by browsers it
is a parallel structure to the DOM and
it has in it semantic information that
screen
and other assistive technologies can use
to present information without
performance implications of everything
else that's in the Dom so the
accessibility tree you can check a
couple different ways if you go to
Chrome colon slash slash accessibility
you can look at a rod dump of the
accessibility tree of every tab that you
have open which you can imagine it's
turned off by default because that would
be pretty big performance hit I have a
post in my slides from the past yellow
group about more on the accessibility
tree including their Windows tool called
a viewer which is also really helpful
for that but when I first got into the
chrome accessibility developer tools I
found on github that they have all of
the all of the library code is out there
under the google chrome organization on
github and down to every audit rule as
it is a JavaScript file and I didn't
quite know what those were for I felt
like Finn from adventure time what do
you do with those well that's where we
get into definitely automated testing
I'm gonna start by showing you a tool by
addy Osmani which is an NPM module
called ali ali is a numeron m for
accessibility so you take out all the
letters in the middle a and y or at the
end if you see me tweeting that a lot
it's because it's shorter but Adi made a
really awesome NPM module and you can
just install it with NPM install ali and
then you require it you get access to
this object that you can then call the
same audit that we ran in the browser
from the command line so i'm going to
show you this instead of putting pulling
it into a javascript file we're just
going to run it from the command line so
i'm going to type a 11 y space cnn.com
and then we're gonna wait and hope that
it resolves it takes a second it's a
little bit longer than the browser
extension but this is actually using
phantom j/s which is a headless browser
so we're not seeing the browser open
this is running on the command line
using phantom going and hitting their
site and then returning an audit back to
us so hopefully this will work slow
conference Wi-Fi yes so the audit that
it gave back to us is the same audit
that we got in the browser extension
except this is a
on the command line so I find that this
report is a little bit harder to digest
than the browser extension but you can
see it tells you the same warnings it
says the controls and media elements
should have labels and then it points
you to a node in the the the Dom tree it
actually shows you the the tree of items
selectors that it actually used to point
you to that node in the browser so this
is pretty cool but I'm not quite sure
how I would use this in a project yet I
will add that there is a grunt task for
Ally that could be useful ways that you
could integrate automated testing for
accessibility what if you ran it on
every save so that you could check
whether something was inaccessible it
might be a little aggressive but you
could also run it on every commit maybe
you wanted to check that you had a
pre-commit hook forget and you could
check whether something is broken more
likely you're gonna run it on a
deployment you're gonna say if you push
out a build that's broken I'm either not
gonna let it go forward or I can use
Travis github to say hey the build is
broken and that person broke it which
leads us to protractor which is the end
end testing framework for angular I'm
focusing on this because I worked on it
but the concepts are similar for any
framework protractor is a node module
that runs on top of selenium webdriver
and what that does is it fires up a
browser programmatically you tell it
where to go
what views to open and you basically set
up your website so that then you can run
tests against it and assert that it's
doing the right thing at the right time
I wrote an accessibility plugin for
protractor that I'll tell you about a
little bit but protractor would be
really useful it's it's what's called
end end testing it's useful for testing
multiple components on a page together
as opposed to unit testing which we'll
talk about in a minute but some things
that you could test for include focus
management like if you are writing a
single page or client rendered app you
could check for live updates like say
your focus is in an input field and at
the act of typing
or something somewhere else on the
screen you want to make sure that those
components are working together that
might be a good thing to test for with
end-to-end testing or color contrast
maybe you want to check the color
contrast across your whole app you could
do that in this as well so to get an
example we're gonna look at angular
material start which I mentioned I've
worked on angular material which is a
component library built on material
design or built on angular using
material design the angular material
start is just a small repository that
you can grab on github to get started
and so I wanted to incorporate the
protractor plug-in into this so I did it
maybe two weeks ago so the interface for
this is pretty simple it only he really
has one one view it has a list of users
on the left side nav and when you click
on one it opens their specific view and
the primary column on the right there's
a little share button and if you tap
that it will open a bottom sheet which
is kind of like a dialog in that it
opens on top of things but it is a sort
of drawer that comes up from the bottom
it's kind of a mobile pattern and
material design the idea with this
though is that it is an interim element
and so when it opens for a keyboard user
or a screen reader user we want to send
their focus they're both so that they
are alerted to new content but also so
that their focus is in the general
location of this new content so this
would be a perfect thing to write a test
for I want to assert that the first
button in the bottom sheet has focus so
some set up that I had to do for
protractor the config file for
protractor this is in the project now
but I had to add a line to enable the
plugins which come with protractor now
those come with the chrome accessibility
developer tools you just have to enable
them in your config it also supports the
tenon API which is an accessibility API
it's super awesome really robust it
requires a subscription and an API key
but that is worth considering as well
and then the other thing I had to do was
add a selenium address in the config
file then in the package.json there
under the dev dependencies there's a
section called scripts and in there you
can put any arbiter
very hook that you want to run from the
command line so for me to run NPM test
for example I put a path to the binary
for protractor it which is the node
module that we download with NPM install
and then the location of the config that
we just looked at so once we have this
setup we can write some tests and so the
tests that are in the project I think
they look a little different now but the
tests for the bottom sheet it assumes
that you have already navigated to the
page and that you have already clicked
on one of the avatars on the left but
the this is a Jasmin test so it starts
with a described statement just an
arbitrary what we're testing and then in
the before each we have to click on that
little share button to get the bottom
sheet open so we're setting up selenium
webdriver to be in the state that we
want to test so once that happens we can
test we can assert that it should focus
on the first item and this there's you
know an infinite number of ways that you
could write a test this was the first
pass I took at this and what I did was I
added through the buttons in the bottom
sheet and when it focuses on one we have
a hold of the active element and so I
just verify that the one we're iterating
over is the same one as the active
element you could do this other ways too
but that was how I verified that the
focus management piece was working so on
top of that that's a test that I wrote
and that is the secret to this plug-in
is that you have to write tests that hit
different parts of your app and then the
plug-in currently it doesn't crawl your
whole app you have to write some tests
and then if you have the plug-in enabled
like I showed you in the config it will
actually run the same audit tools that
we are the audits that we run in ran in
the browser extension and Adys tool same
library it will run those against your
markup in protractor which is really
cool and material start actually
everything passed so I had to make it
fail just to show you what a failure
looked like ironically the pass and fail
messages on the command line are in red
green which I have heard are a little
hard to see for some people so that's a
change that we need to make but it does
also say pass and fail in text so it's
not relying on call
alone but that's an improvement that I
would like to make which I can imagine I
mean even on a different monitor could
be harder to see and then quickly I'll
mention again that tenon API is another
option and if you're interested in that
you can go and look at the protractor
documentation but to fix those failures
that I made fail on purpose the the view
for the bottom sheet it has a list of
contacts that it iterates over an object
and for each item there's a button with
an icon in it I just removed the text
from the icons so that it would fail and
then to fix it I just add the text back
in which you can see highlighted and
then we're going to run it on the
command line and see if it works so I
have command line in my slides and I'm
just typing NPM test that's the hook
that we put into package JSON so I have
selenium webdriver
running in another tab in my terminal we
can see selenium open up the browser and
now I have to go back to the slide so
the difference between a DS tool and
this one was a DS used phantom so it
didn't open another browser it didn't
move our focus away with protractor it's
actually using webdriver to fire up a
browser we specified chrome in the
config but you could fire up Firefox you
could run it in other environments but
what that's doing is actually running
our tests against that real browser and
then since I fixed the the code in the
HTML now it passes all of the that the
failures that we had before we can also
see that there are in the actual
material start there are two tests I
only showed you one of them but that the
actual real project which I'm running on
my computer that has two tests and then
we have the plug-in enabled so on top of
our tests it runs the chrome
accessibility audit it's pretty awesome
I'm pretty stoked about that so in
comparison unit testing and actually
this is something I use more in my
day-to-day work as a developer unit
testing is different in different from
and and testing and that you need to
write tests for individual components
things you could test are
Aria properties that need to change with
user interaction keyboard operability to
make sure that tabindex is enabled and
keyboard commands work text alternatives
making sure for example if you had an
icon button and you wanted to make sure
that it had a label enforced or it fell
back to a label or something semantics
as well so unit testing is a really
great way like if you're not already
doing unit testing you should be that's
what I went to learn at my last job but
accessibility fits in with that so well
because you all of a sudden have test
coverage across your whole app for
accessibility so an example that I use a
lot is that I am the primary contributor
to ng Aria the accessibility module for
angular and there's some things that I
like about it some things I want to
change but I have an example of a custom
checkbox and it's a custom element with
web components and just custom HTML now
you can write any tag name you want so I
have some - checkbox and then using ng
model and ng checked in angular I can
have it dynamically add attributes so
what ng aria is doing is ensuring that
the Aria checked attribute is on the
element as well as the checked attribute
so if I uncheck the checkbox we see Aria
checked change to false and we see the
html5 checked attribute go away because
it and that actually checked is what it
ng checked is adding but because this
isn't a real checkbox it's not an input
we need aria to actually tell the
accessibility tree and a screen reader
that it's checked or unchecked but the
one thing that we want to look at here
is that this has tabindex so the ng
model when it detects a role of checkbox
or there are certain scenarios where it
will add tabindex dynamically and that
is what I want to show you the test for
I'm actually refactoring ng Aria right
now because it's a bit too liberal with
the attributes that it adds so I have
some tests in my refactored version that
I'm working on locally about which
elements it should attach to and because
angular has thousands of unit tests I
usually use I will isolate to the ng
Aria tests
so I date that it should not attach to
native controls meeting buttons if they
put ng click on a button it doesn't need
to have an X it should attach to custom
inputs and it should attach to elements
with ng click like divs so this is the
kind of stuff that ng Aria the
opportunity that we have to actually
improve angular applications and
accessibility but we need a little bit
of finessing to get this module in a
better place so unit testing is
obviously a huge part of that actually
I'll talk a little bit more about that
since we have some more time than I
thought we would the unit testing every
time I go to add a feature to something
like ng Aria or angular material I will
start with the test test-driven
development we're probably all familiar
with it but for accessibility you can
even do that so when I went to make
these changes to ng Aria I would
actually start with the test and it
would fail because ng Aria is doing
things that it shouldn't right now it
adds tabindex to a native button so I
start by writing the test and then I go
back to the code and then I make the
changes to get all the tests to pass
there was actually a lot of features in
ng Aria so it wasn't as easy as I
thought it would be but that should be
coming up pretty soon so today we've
talked about keyboard and screen reader
testing as a manual way to actually
check or diagnose the accessibility of
an app we looked at sort of automated
tools like the Firefox web developer
toolbar and the chrome accessibility
developer tools which the latter the
chrome tool I would highly recommend
using Firefox the web developer toolbar
is cool it's a little more dated and I'd
say the the heading feature is the only
one that I really use but then in
automated testing we talked about a DS
Alley module and protractor there's
other tools out there like quail and
tenon and all these really cool things
that you could use to automate
accessibility testing and there's more
of a culture like I'm up here talking to
you about it at J's comp I never thought
that this would be a subject that people
would want to hear about but it's
starting to change and there are more
tools and more resources for us as
developers to actually make the world
better make a more accessible web so
it's really exciting to see these things
start to happen
in case you're like whoa okay I know
about automated stuff but I don't know
anything about accessibility I have a
ton of resources and my slides including
including people with disabilities and
user research because that's something
we should be doing conducting user
evaluations as developers I always think
it's really cool and I get to go do a
different task than development like
interviewing users I think that's really
valuable I have a couple blog posts
about auditing website for accessibility
of recent one from Smashing Magazine on
notes on client rendered accessibility
there's some more tooling on a w3c post
about web accessibility evaluation tools
the web aim screen reader survey is the
closest thing we have to analytics for
accessibility you can go and check what
do people self-report what are they
telling us that they use for browsers
and screen readers and we can basically
look at that and then look at our own
analytics to tell you know do I really
need to support i8 you could go and
check and then a little bit on what is
Aria because I didn't go into that very
much so that means that we're at the end
and there may be something awesome
happening now Beyonce dancing with like
a pizza coming out I think is a win
alone we're actually done a little bit
early so I wanted to say in case you
don't get a slice of pizza I have some
Pizza buttons that I would be happy to
give to you and you can come and find me
at any time and ask me questions that
accessibility I'm pretty passionate
about it obviously our magic thing is
not not happening
oh that sucks
you know I had a really good run last
year was amazing and I guess it's just
not happening what was supposed to
happen was that there was supposed to be
a pizza that came out I actually really
want pizza I skip the afternoon snack so
it just my dreams are foiled your pizza
dreams as a as a consolation prize I
have an inflatable pizza slice that we
can play with in the pool I don't know
if you heard about that I'm really glad
I brought that now because I'm so let
down that the pizza didn't show up give
them an angry phone call anyway thanks
for letting me doddle here for a minute
but it's been really fun talking to you
so thanks
you